16 septembre à l'aube dans le pays du
bout chaunois la géologue se réveille un
géologue se réveille elle se réveille se
réveille réveille la bouillabaisse
elle est sublimement magnifique puise
elle enfile sa tenue de géologues la
géologue est à la recherche du minéral
le plus précieux qu'elle connaisse la
patite
pierre ne réagit pas ce n'est donc pas
de l'apatite
un géologue prend mignonnette sa
stagiaire et mignonnette son vin rouge
et part au travail
la géologue a beaucoup de choses à
apprendre à sa stagiaire mignonnette
[Musique]
lapierre ne réagit pas ce n'est donc pas
de l'apathie pierre ne réagit pas ce
n'est donc pas de l'apatite
[Musique]
non non non non et au au jeu le bon
l'est pas
[Musique]
la géologue commence par aller voir les
réserves minéralogique du musée le plus
proche
après cette matinée éprouvante
la géologue savoure quelques minutes de
repos bien mérité avec sa stagiaire
mignonnette devant un bon repas
[Musique]
c'est marrant parce qu'en fait quand tu
regardes tes lazaina comme ça ça fait
comme des couches doigt des couches des
couches sédimentaires du coup tu vois
quand elle annonce celle des jeunes du
coup ça te fait des gens de défis
surtout donald comme ça si jamais tu as
un déplacement comme ça ça on appelle ça
une faille du coup quand un déplacement
comme ça ne partait donc là c'est une
faille coulissantes
si jamais sa montée lente sur l'autre ce
serait une faille inverse et si ça
s'écarte comme ça et ben c'est une
famille normale et tu manges rien là
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu as pas fait
c'est parce que j'ai vu que tu veux un
dessin aux petits gradins
après ce repas sur le pouce
la géologue et sa stagiaire mignonnette
parts sur le terrain
[Musique]
l'occasion pour la géologue de dispenser
son savoir à mignonnette sa stagiaire
on tient bien ses mignonettes les
plantes camille des géologues sa cache
les cailloux la géologue cherche
toujours de l'apatite sans succès en
revanche elle vient de découvrir par
sérendipité une belle pépite au regarde
assez impressionnant mais oui regarde ça
un conte prolixe un kaka faux cindy
moine dont cette crotte que tu vois là à
70 millions d'années
c'est fou à aa
lors de leur pause la géologue et sa
stagiaire font un chiffon me du géologue
égalité égalité
égalité égalité égalité
égalité égalité vexé de cette égalité
la géologue teste sa stagiaire à l'acide
chlorhydrique elle ne réagit pas ce
n'est donc pas de l'apatite à défaut
d'avoir trouvé de l'apatite la géologue
est contente de sa récolte du jour elle
a trouvé plein de nouveau caillou pour
sa collection
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dure journée est terminée
la géologue arranger ça mignonnette et
profite d'un repos bien mérité
la géologue a trouvé son apatite
oh
[Musique]
un géologue va se coucher elle va se
coucher elle va se coucher
[Musique]
la bouillabaisse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la fin tout ça n'a pas marché bref si
jamais tu as un déplacement pas comme ça
et bien à ce moment-là on appelle ça une
feuille